[Music]
so you
righty my girl withth riding to is hard
to
[Music]
find not if you know where to look I'll
miss you every
second major Egan you were the first
pilot ass sign of the 100s me and B clev
you are in charge of 35 planes and 350
air
crewmen don't you'd die on me before I
get over
there something big is brewing the to be
sending up the largest air alada ever
assembled in the history of mankind
straight into Hitler's
territory we need complete and total air
superiority that's the
mission what might be the last pretty
face I ever
[Music]
see
what's the
move we lead our poys
Throne all then we
do day in day out does something to a
guy doesn't it we here to fight the
monsters the things these people are
capable of they got to come
trust
me Lord guard and guide The Men Who fly
through the great spaces of the sky are
we T men or what sir yes sir be with
them traversing the air in darkening
storms or Sunshine fair I think we may
be done we are going to sit here and
take it we're going to stick with our
mission as long as we can
fly we won't go without a
fight
[Music]